hey guys thanks for tuning in so I
uploaded a video a while back on
modafinil the real limitless drug and
that was very popular it's actually the
number one video on YouTube
if you just search my dad knows this
worked out well as you could imagine
that's led to quite a few questions and
seems people are very interested in the
Daphne hat works and some of the smaller
aspects of it so I thought I'd answer
some of the most common ones here in
this video hopefully answer your
questions and give you a bit more
insight into this new trick and so
randomly one of the questions I received
the most which I wouldn't have expected
is his modafinil useful for exercise
will it help give me more energy more
focus in the gym and my personal
experience on that is no not at all
that's because a for me increases heart
rate in a similar manner as caffeine and
B because it seems to affect my sleep
negatively meaning I'm kind of tired
exhausted just don't have much energy
focus it's more kind of like I'm being
kept awake against my will when I take
the Daphna as opposed to I have loads of
extra boundless energy some of the free
workouts designed to increase the energy
in the gym are making caffeine just lots
of caffeine essentially people say they
like those I think it's a great idea but
you want to give that game then sure go
ahead but personally my experience
knowing that one of the reasons I
designed that and one you
that on a regular basis was like
blocking ability and as a result my
workouts and suffered and I got thinner
so I would say due to that one one of
the things that the doctor and Kathleen
do to increase your energy levels is to
increase no adrenaline nor fight right
which is one of the vital white
responses hormones there are other ways
you can induce that for instance even
during a cardio workout the small cardio
workouts at the beginning will increase
adrenaline a cold shower will increase
and increase adrenaline I'll wake you up
and get your focus help getting at the
brain frog so that's something that you
can use instead quick cardio workout
with walnuts I'll actually have a very
similar effect to taking some kind of
caffeine based free workout so yeah but
that mill for free workout new is is the
answer to that
after losing weight I am added modafinil
could be a little bit useful way as an
appetite suppressant you buy me you work
for ages I think there's an advert
expectancy of straight legs to whatever
you're doing that you don't actually
feel hungry we're gonna let healthy I'm
not sure again I wouldn't recommend
using it for that however than being
honest then yes if what we could be
useful for losing weight but just don't
also increasing your heart rate and your
adrenalin stuff already
so you don't want to get yourself talk
computations then yeah especially if we
use it because these something likes
about their own so I've got a very
intensive CV I think you could have to
quickly address if that means you go
quite yes we traced a few times but that
look working out they already take is
that
or be much more logical question today
is how does my dad know work that's
something that see people seem to ask
surprisingly little but I still feel
it's worth mentioning and that's the
problem we don't actually know what I
understand how modafinil works there's a
theory that effects the Reston's which
are a type of neurotransmitter that
triggers arrest in neurons and these
neurons Beach into certain parts the
brain to deal with wakefulness
remember that modafinil is originally
supposed to be a wakefulness drug is
supposed to treat narcolepsy so that's
its main function and this effects
arranger neurotransmitters which have
been seen to rise in the brain when
someone's using modafinil they include
dopamine they include noradrenaline or
pan-fried they include serotonin
produces garber and it increases
histamines so really this is very
similar actually to the results you get
me take caffeine it basically counts the
body are consumed in a kind of fight or
flight mode
dopamine is the reward near transmitter
that's what many people know it as but
it doesn't it's nicely that simple it's
not so much that that we gives you that
sense of reward you get from doing
things rather it's used as a way to kind
of cement an action so if you do
something and don't mean is released
then you're more like to do it next time
it's a kind of reinforcing and so in a
way it kind of tells you what's
important so wall of dopamine in your
brain needs essentially more attention
this increases the neural activity in
your brain and to respond to that
Ukraine also increases its release
give you much even more perfectas almost
definitely if you've all focused lets
you have more television rather than
your brain wandering off through the
myriad networks of your mind
so kiss basically gives you that kind of
television elastic focus on something
keep your weight as well because it's
also potentially less creative if I go
into detail on this on my blog I talk a
lot more about how it works
that's the basics so the way it's kind
of like super caffeine accepting don't
100% know how it works and what's
important to remember is that our you
changed the neo chemistry of your brain
it adapts over time this is how you
build up tolerance to any drug kathleen
included and if you're building a
tolerance everything means you'll have
fewer of those neurotransmitters in your
brain by default so if you use an
adapter all the time then you're all
burst a battery does then you're almost
guaranteed to reduce the amount of
dopamine the your brain produces
naturally so you might find that
eventually you find it more difficult to
focus this also means it could
potentially be addictive there's no
studies to show that the Daphna fictive
and space have no side effect although I
mentioned in my last video I did
experience some side effects myself but
anything that increases daily
is like it's being predicted in some
fashion and it's also course
psychologically addictive because you
feel like that that's a word to see more
like to want to use it again
say that's the basics of how it works
you can get more detail on my website no
we don't really know and with a network
that's a problem so to me that's good
reason not use it certainly not these
are on regular basis remember as well
that near conferences have a kind of
cascading effect if one gets increased
that increases brain activity that
releases that rhythm leads to an
increase of another new transmitter
which meanwhile drops another one so you
might take it for one purpose and find
there's all kinds of not gonna text on
the brain it's not a very precise method
to use any new trick but to try and
change your brain chemistry you really
want to scalpel others is like using a
shotgun so yeah be careful of that and
again I wouldn't recommend using it the
only time I would say that it's probably
useful to use wietrow this is is in a
kind of very precise fashion when you
want to learn something and the data can
increase your memory retention in the
same ways that caffeine can increase
your focus so I recommend not using it
but then if you read must play around
these things which I don't think is
terribly safe but if you really must use
it
as a kind of weapon to really enhance
your learning because it is - that's not
will it'll be more effective and at the
same time you won't get the you won't
get the same long-term side effects
which will come with long tolerance
somebody asked me have a deaf girl
effective gaming which is quite
interesting and one thing I did find
actually as I played see Pentagon and I
actually let myself get dick better to
see pecs gone quicker then I probably
would have done otherwise when I was
using the adapter was in I was already
playing it and I tried it for a bit
whilst using the Daphnia and during that
time my performance on that game
increased faster so I was more able to
more quickly progress through the levels
that makes sense
if you think of it in terms of the focus
in the memory again building more neural
connections it could essentially
slightly enhance plasticity I'm not
gonna yeah I said as definitely I'd open
is a studies just thing that but I think
it's possible
so again if you're gonna learn new
language or something you might gonna
use it just once or twice to kind of
really have a cram session it can
improve reaction times and things like
that is used by sprinters which is
interesting sprinters like to use it in
order to increase the reaction time
getting off the starting line when they
near the gun so it can make you
today the last thing is alternative so
they're safe or healthy alternative
surely caffeine is evocative overlap and
its own drawbacks we tried something a
little more potent like year the main
team that has caffeine in it as well as
two others anthias darling - the perfect
didn't love it - around the moocher
little st. very easy to come by and less
concerning them modafinil but really I
think the best alternatives are things
like increasing your sleep which will
100% Nikki much better meth much focused
much happier but more created all these
things and include your body getting
more sunlight to just break your brain
and for wakefulness you know meditating
is produced when women dark roots so
keep yourself in in the light and you're
gonna stay more awake exercise it's
fantastic improving your memory and
losing your attention and as I said you
can even use it in a short-term increase
adrenaline a cold shower
if diet is highly important and more
long-term better much more useful than
just giving yourself that one burst so
as much as the idea of a new treatment
like that little coconut increase your
focus change your brain in amazing ways
like a limitless might be appealing it's
actually probably not that smart
because you get ready wait you see take
will ignite your fatal side effects
might cause some kind of adaption which
you didn't attend but making else
they're gonna have works it's like just
messin it's like when you trying to fix
me see I'm just back it so you do it it
break when you use a new treadmill or
anything really
we just don't understand that they're
kind of make this fine sheet changes
thanks for watching I'll see you next
time adios